(brouhaha)
- Une messe dominicale
qui tourne au drame en Égypte.
Un incendie s'est déclaré dans
ce bâtiment abritant une église
copte orthodoxe aux alentours
de 9 h ce matin.
5000 fidèles s'y étaient
rassemblés pour prier.
La tragédie s'est produite
dans le quartier très dense
et populeux d'Imbaba,
dans la ville de Gizeh.
C'est la deuxième plus grande
ville d'Égypte après Le Caire,s.
Des témoins racontent
que les flammes ont bloqué
l'entrée de l'égli
la seule porte de sortie,
et dans la détresse,
provoqué une bousculade.
"Certaines personnes se sont
jetées par les fenêtres
pour échapper au feu",
raconte ce témoin.
L'incendie s'est aussi étend
à une garderie et fait
beaucoup de jeunes victimes.
"Il y avait des enfants
et des aînés. Nous avons sauvé
tous ceux que nous pouvions",
raconte ce blessé.
En tout, 15 camions de pompiers
et des det des det des det des s
ont été dépêchés sur les lieux.
Mais les rues étroites
et sinueuses ont compliqué
les opérations.
L'origine de l'incendie
reste à éclaircir.
Le ministère de l'Intérieur
privilégie la piste
d'un faux contact électrique
dans un climatiseur vétuste
du bâtiment; d'autres évoquent
la surcharge d'une génératrice.
Le parquet égyptien a ouvert
une enquête.
Sur Twitter, le président
égyptien Abdel Fati
a présenté ses condoléances
"aux familles des victimes
innocentes qui sont parties
rejoindre leur Seigneur dansl'u,
écrit-il.
Il faut dire que les incendies
meurtriers ne sont pas raresdane
du Caire. Des millions
d'Égyptiens vivent dans
des quartiers informels,
dotés d'infrastrucinfrastrucinfs
mal entretenues.
Ici Louis-Philippe Trozzo,
Radio-Canada, Mon